so let's talk about some Secrets we're
going to start with a few from Elden
ring but then we're going to dive back
into secrets from from software's other
games which I'm very excited about it's
been too long number one did you know
that the heirloom set of talismans
appear to be based on a real-life
historical artifact so this is the
Hockley pendant it's a diamond shaped
piece of jewelry that depicts a female
Saint supporting a cross specifically
it's a relicary pendant which means it
has a sliding panel on the back that's
designed to hold a small Relic this
piece of treasure dates back to the 16th
century and was discovered by a young
boy in the UK in 2010 making headlines
and all kinds of places including Reddit
where the first comment I saw was this
is the mother Flippin star Scourge
heirloom from Elden ring of course it's
the exact same color and shape as all
four heirloom talismans and it goes to
show the depth of research that the
design team does their rings and their
talismans but of course Elden ring pulls
inspiration from previous from software
titles more than anything else so to
some of you this next secret might bring
up some painful memories do you remember
that purple binding spell that the
larger finger creepers can cast
well it's binding animation is actually
exactly the same as the one found way
back in the original Demon Souls this
attack made the Mind flayers absolutely
terrifying from a gameplay point of view
as they always followed up this attack
with a crazy powerful grab attack
just like the finger creepers would go
on to do 13 years later in Elden ring
and luckily this projectile is a lot
easier to dodge now and if you want to
learn more about it go and check out
amir's video on the topic there's even
an unused damage state in that video he
talks about which forces your character
to walk in a sickly manner just like
they do when in feebled in sakuru as
always all creators are linked in the
description and I highly recommend that
you subscribe to all of them just so you
can enrich the quality of souls content
you consume on YouTube but speaking of
reused assets here is one that just
refuses to die so originally a location
called God's grave was planned to appear
in Dark Souls 3 but then this map and
its assets and even its soundtrack which
I'll play for you here they all were
abandoned until later when the ringed
City DLC was released and gravestones
from this place were finally featured in
the game but then data Miner Lance
McDonald pointed out that an asset in
Elden ring still references God grave to
this day here at the end of Castle mourn
a huge Tombstone with a hole in the
middle continues to be used as an asset
it's not really clear who these Graves
belong to in Olden ring but now part of
me is wondering if it's not the grave of
a god regardless someone at from
software really likes this design and
just won't let it go next remember that
cinematic scene way back that was
released with Elden Ring's story trailer
where a clean rot night thrusts a spear
into radon it's just one of many Spears
that now remain in his body and one of
many clean Rod Knights that litter this
ancient battlefield but did you know
that a living clean rot night Still
Remains here in this Arena well at least
it does in version 1.0 of Elden ring and
if you disconnect your internet and disk
install Elden
you should be able to find this clean
Road Knight here as well still alive in
the arena for number five do you
remember fighting this Knight Commander
here at Castle height so as you may know
this Knight features in Kenneth Heights
quest line and he is described as a
knight commander of stormvale who is
simply obsessed with blood fittingly
then he does use a bloody slash attack
which makes him a unique enemy but did
you know that it goes further than that
so recently I noticed that if blood loss
is triggered in the vicinity when you
fight him then the Knight will get an
attack power boost as shown by this red
glow on his character so this boost is
actually a bonus granted by the Lord of
Bloods exaltation Talisman which is a
Talisman that we can find in-game on
eska a priest of blood boss who is
clearly an adherent of Moog the Lord of
blood the talisman's description invites
these adherents to render up offerings
of blood to their lord so it follows
that this Knight isn't just obsessed
with blood he's actually been
indoctrinated fully into moog's order
and might not be too loyal to godric and
stormvale anymore as a result and
speaking of blood the first Gameplay
trailer for bloodborne aired all the way
back in 2014 and interestingly this
official trailer actually contains a
kick animation right here but as you may
know the ability to kick enemies was
obviously cut from the final game but it
does still exist in the game's code and
as discovered by renowned modder Lance
McDonald it can be restored by
uncommenting two lines of code and in
retrospect the decision to remove it
makes a lot of sense for one not enough
enemies in this game carry Shields this
isn't a medieval setting and not just
that but bloodborne has an incredibly
frantic pace of combat it's bad enough
doing accidental kicks in Dark Souls and
it would have been even more annoying to
kick while frantically mashing buttons
in bloodborne also cut from the final
version of bloodborne was a compass
which in early development would appear
on the UI When you entered a chalice
dungeon as pointed out by Lance on
Twitter though it wasn't used in the
final game the code has remained in from
software's engines ever since until it
was finally Incorporated in Eldon ring
Julie the witch also mentioned that Dark
Souls also had a compass at one point
which could be enabled from the debug
menu
for number eight there was also an
attack that the shadow of yarn emboss
was meant to use that was cut which
showed the enemy giving up on their
snake attacks and just you know getting
with the times and pulling out a shotgun
instead Lance uncovered this one as well
but it appears it was left on The
Cutting Room floor quite early in
development given it has no visual
effects and doesn't do any damage so if
you don't know Lance is the one who
famously designed a 60 FPS patch for
bloodborne which can run beautifully if
you have the right PS4 or PS4 Pro a
while back Lance even showcased a 60 FPS
version of the game with 4k upscaling on
PS5 to the folks over a digital Foundry
and they made a video on it and I'd
highly recommend you check out that
video halfway through they discussed the
prospects and the difficulties
surrounding an official 60 FPS patch for
bloodborne and it's an interesting
discussion basically they concluded that
patching bloodborne to unlock 60 FPS is
a bit of a development nightmare since
remounting the entire game and updating
it with new code is not just tricky but
also likely it requires a new
contractual agreement between Sony and
from software my personal theory is that
from software and Sony are hesitating to
implement a 60 FPS patch for bloodborne
because they'd rather just sell it as a
remaster and make a big deal about it
when that time finally comes they did
recently acquire blue point games after
all who remade Demon Souls but that's
just a theory there's so many fake
rumors that fly around about bloodborne
getting a remaster or a sequel so I
recommend you really don't believe
anything until we get an official Source
but in my opinion it does seem
inevitable that something will be done
with the bloodborne IP eventually I
think it's just a matter of time
bloodborne is so beloved that it even
lives on in other PlayStation games
recently a poem written about yarnum can
be found in God of War Ragnarok in the
game you collect a series of books
called kavasia's poems and each pays
homage to a different PlayStation game
bloodborne's is titled sanguinity and it
reads kill and die wound and sigh bleed
and perish slash and cry inject and
deflect think and reflect fire expire
murder in fact the moon grows Crimson
the Mad townsfolk shout the city a
prison carve your way out the cover of
this book then features the Hunter's
Mark which is another fun Easter egg but
before I go on I want to quickly talk
about this video's sponsor which is
factor 75. factor offers these great
pre-prepared meals that are ready to eat
in two minutes or less with a rotating
weekly menu of over 27mm
and 33 add-ons like smoothies and keto
shakes and desserts and more I've been
trying to lose a bit of weight myself
recently and honestly it helps so much
when you have convenient meals on hand
that you know will help you to achieve
your daily goals it adds purpose and
convenience and predictability to your
day not to mention it helps you avoid
fast food and ordering in and with these
Chef prepared meals there's little
guesswork involved so you'll never have
to opt for something that isn't good for
you so please use the link in the
description below or go to
go.factor75.com and use code pogvidia
Feb 50 for 50 off your first box now
back to the video with number 11.
another interesting secret recently
revealed about bloodborne is that at
least one of its songs is written with
Latin lyrics Antonius tertius on YouTube
was able to get in touch with a music
producer who worked on the game and they
finally offered a translation of the
lyrics for Lawrence the first vicar so
if we listen really carefully to the
opening few lines from this song we can
just make out lyrics that painter
haunting and fitting picture for
Lawrence according to tertius these
Latin lyrics are as I've written them on
screen however the music produces
original lyrics are slightly different
as they represent a closer
interpretation of what the team wanted
them to mean they once read if you
desire mystery and learn you shall be
rewarded attain the Holy Blood you shall
be rewarded The Secret of Holy Blood we
attain Humanity surpass and lose it
attain the Holy Blood make sure to check
out the rest of antonius's video for
extra details on the lyrical and the
grammatical changes as well here
shifting gears here a bit did you know
that you can only kill flying birds in
one from software game limit Breakers
has an entire video on this if you want
to go and watch it before I spoil it but
I'll give you a second and to try and
guess which game
and it's Demon Souls while you may be
able to stab or shoot them when they're
on the ground in bloodborne and Elden
ring the only game that lets you shoot
birds out of the sky is Demon Souls it
may take you many many attempts but the
end result will reward you with white
arrows
these arrows are really powerful which
makes them a really good choice for
taking out larger enemies but when it
comes to the red dragon in Demon Souls
did you know that you can put these
arrows aside and just defeat it with a
melee build instead it's true and it
will make picking up the rewards that it
guards a lot easier so how do you
accomplish this well if you stand right
here on the bridge on the Lord's path in
boletaria Palace you can actually hit
the dragon's tail with a long weapon in
hand such as a great sword or a halberd
as it flies down and breathes fire on
the bridge it's a bit tedious and you
can't even do this with a shorter weapon
if you're crazy but it is a lot more
efficient than firing a ton of arrows
and wasting them it will also net you
17K souls in the early game if you're
patient enough to do it this works in
the original game and the Remake as well
and while the Remake was a great success
did you know that there are still very
passionate fans of the original Demon
Souls that are still maintaining its
online systems even after the official
systems were taken down so the original
Demon Souls servers were shut down in
February of 2018 but it didn't take long
for fans to find a solution the arch
stones are a private server that were
created as a way to preserve the game's
original online experience it stores
online functionality for the PS3 and PC
emulators as well and it even has a
colossal community of 35 000 members on
Discord this server was created by a
security engineer named UV with the help
of a Reddit user named ymgve who had
begun Gathering data needed to recreate
the game servers after they were
initially shut down UV explains in an
interview with IGN that one of the great
things about Demon Souls was that the
network traffic was sent in almost plain
text which made it a lot easier to
understand how its elements worked once
you'd figured out the encryption and
even with the Remake out in the world UV
Promises to Keep the arch Stones running
saying that no matter what happens my
server will stay there as there will
always be an audience for the original
experience so can we just celebrate that
people like this exist in the community
it's such a crazy initiative to take on
so please set this up for yourself and
thank these people to set this up on
your console or PC check out their
website in the description below moving
on to Dark Souls I think this game more
than any others had the most interesting
marketing campaigns and thankfully a lot
of them have been enshrined on the lore
Hunters channel so please go and check
out his video but he compiled some of
the most memorable ones from slashy
Souls which was this free to play mobile
game created in the lead up to Dark
Souls 3's release that endured a very
rough reception and then there were
statues that were super memorable and
even the coffin rig so this last one was
kind of Unforgettable it was actually
made for a competition here in Australia
after the release of Dark Souls and it's
exactly what it sounds like it was a
gaming setup fashioned into a coffin
complete with a monitor surround sound
and housing for a console as well in
this setup you truly were prepared to
die and the marketing Dramatics don't
end there though I remember being there
for this one at E3 where we saw this
statue that depicted this huge fountain
of blood from a character thrusting a
sword into a corpse and in retrospect
this was featuring a mechanic that ended
up being cut from the game Lance
McDonald uncovered it after the game's
release and it had a whole gameplay
function that I guess must have been in
the game when they commissioned the
statue anyway please go and check out
more details in this video by the lore
Hunter and check out the rest of the
content on his channel as well which now
dives into the lore of Elden ring as
well for number 16 it's insane to me
that we're still learning new things
about these games to this day for
example recently limit Breakers
discovered that the Frog rays in Dark
Souls when brought to water pools
actually transition into a Glide
animation and even have a hidden attack
so when they're in these pools and only
here will they spit at you and while
this attack doesn't have an effect even
when it's restored now you can tell that
they were planning something for these
little guys originally for number 17 I
want to talk about something else in
Dark Souls and that's man-eater Mildred
so she invades you near the second
bonfire in Blighttown which is quite a
memorable experience and potentially
your first Invasion up to that point she
has a very fun origin story so before
she was a Canon character she was
actually a play tester so on a Japanese
podcast a long time ago Miyazaki
explained that during the debugging
stage of Dark Souls development a player
dressed in Manny to Mildred's weird Garb
invaded a session and on impulse the
team decided to replicate The Invader as
an NPC because they just liked the idea
and it must have been a memorable
experience for them as well to get
invaded in these early days and to this
day a butcher woman has been featured in
most of from software's subsequent games
Dark Souls 2 features Melinda the
butcher there's the mad woman in Dark
Souls 3 and even Anastasia the tarnished
eater in Elden ring you could sort of
also argue that bloodborne has a butcher
Invader as well with the younger madaras
twin who dons the butcher set so they
really left quite an impact on this
series and it's crazy that it was all
spawned from one playtester it's always
fun to learn what inspired Miyazaki and
the team I wish we got more interviews
where they just talk about the creation
process Behind these games one of these
inspiration sources for Miyazaki at
least has been known for quite some time
and that's Magic the Gathering and many
people have noticed that there have been
similarities between certain cards and
characters that are now within from
software's Worlds so here's another one
that I haven't really seen talked about
too much as pointed out to me by or rely
of Norden Twitter a perfect example
might lie with painter's servant printed
in 2008 which we think might have
inspired slave nightgale the flavor text
of the card reads that it gathers Hues
from the Twilight Mist so that its
Master can paint a better world which
has similarities to Gale's Soul
description which reads the red hooded
wandering slave nightgale sought the
blood of the Dark Soul as pigment for
the painted world so much like the
painter's servant gathers Hues for its
Master Gail seeks to gather the pigment
from the Dark Soul to give to the
painter so that she can paint a better
world something that will make a good
home and will be a cold dark and very
gentle place
so that one looks pretty familiar to me
but I want to know have you ever come
across a MTG card that looked familiar
to a theme or a character or an enemy in
one of from software's games I'm a big
fan of other card games I've never
really played Magic the Gathering but I
am getting more into collecting and
learning about it lately so I'd love to
learn more about any other connections
you guys know about to finish off here's
two short secular secrets so as you
might know from my previous Secrets
video I was going through all of the
design Works art books recently and I
came across this picture of Al where he
stands next to his owl and you can just
see the similarities between them this
reminded me of a Zulily the witch video
where she takes a closer look at the owl
in game as well and it's just stunning
how similar the two are as it turns out
the owl only has one eye open similar to
Father owl except it's on the opposite
side probably a design needs tell that
you wouldn't catch unless you freeze
frame the game and look closely but it's
always crazy to see how much detail the
developers go into but it's not just the
developers that can be incredibly
creative it's also crazy how creative
some players can be while fighting in
this game and I want to talk about one
of ongbal's videos I wanted to shout out
ongbal for ages he makes these crazy
fight montages where he fights in like
the most efficient way possible never
missing a opportunity to attack or Parry
perfectly his videos are fun to watch so
they discovered an interesting way to
take out the Sakura Bull in Fountainhead
Palace all it requires is a bit of
stealth for this shocking result so with
the help of the Okami leader that throws
lightning near the palace entrance you
can actually lure the bull into a trap
where then you can attack it with that
lightning ongbal accomplished this by
staying underneath the ball and
following it until it was near the
shrine's entry entrance and then at the
very corner he throws fireworks to get
it stuck and then from there he performs
a lightning reversal when the Okami
leader throws a bolt their way and you
can deflect this at the bull and it's a
surprisingly effective way to take out
this enemy I guess
but the crazy thing to me was that the
bull even had an animation for being
electrocuted considering this is not
something that you can normally do so I
found that crazy I found so many of
these secrets entertaining so as always
thank you for watching please go and
check out all the creators in the
description check out Factor 75 if you
want to support the channel and get some
good meals and I'll see you in the next
one